Having implicitly unwrapped optionals
automatically sprinkled throughout your
code base, is sub optimal at best.
Apple realized this and
has addressed this problem by
providing nullability annotations.
Nullability annotations clarify which
variables have the potential to carry
null values.
These annotations are pretty
straight forward.
And they include nullable and nonnull.
As you might expect, nullable
pointers can have nil values and
nonnull pointers cannot.
So let's go ahead and
annotate our user class.
In this case name and
email will be nonnull because every
user must have a name and email.
But avatar should be nullable.
Now, see how this warning
pops up down here?
As soon as you add nullability
annotations at one place,
the compiler will start encouraging
you to add them everywhere.
It's all or nothing.
No problem.
We just need to add in annotations
to the two parameters.
Email and name are still both nonnull.
The compiler is still complaining and
it's pointing to this return type.
To know how to annotate the return type
we'll need to look at the initializer in
the .M file.
Notice that this custom initializer can
return nil if email verification fails.
So we'll go back to the header file and
we'll mark this return type as nullable
since sometimes it can be nil.
There, now the compiler is happy,
let's see what our generated
header looks like now.
Again, we go up to this icon in the
upper left, click generated interface.
Okay, now this is what we like to see,
no exclamation points.
The properties that we
marked as non null,
name and email,
are interpreted as regular variables.
The Aaatar property, which we
marked nullable, is a respectable
explicitly unwrapped optional, and so
is the return type for the initializer.